بعيدا عن الحرب وبحثا عن الامان تسعى ليلا
للهجره الى ارض قصيه تقلب صفحات الذكريات
مع زوجها قديم وتخوض صراعا بين الرغبه في
الامان والخشيه من فراغ غربه لن يسعها
ملئه ليتفق الزوجان كثيرا على القرار لكنه
حسم تقريبا
قطعه صفارات الانذار مقابلتنا مع الزوجين
وسريعا بدا الاجراء اللازم باختباء اولي
داخل المنزل
نضطر للاحتماء خلف جدارين على الاقل خوفا
من سقوط المقذوف او الحطام
يستخدم كملجا علينا النزول سته طوابق
وسنكون بامان اكبر
ضمن الاجراءات الواجب اتباعها الذهاب نحو
مراب السيارات في المبنى للاحتماء وهناك
كان اخرون
سافرت بناتي الى كندا نعتقدون الحرب ستكون
اطول مما يتوقع كثيرون انت كررت المصاعب
من القطاع الكهرباء والمياه سيتاثر
الاقتصاد والناس بشكل اكبر سيكون الوضع
اصعب قصه من اصل ملايين القصص لاناس
غادروا ويغادرون اوكرانيا بسبب الحرب
ارقام كبيره تتحدث عن نزيف سكانيا ليس
بالسهل وتطرح اسئله عديده بشان هذا التغير
الديموغرافي وكيف سيؤثر على الامن القومي
حسب بعض التقديرات فان اوكرانيا مرت بثلاث
مراحل ديموغرافيه اولى بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي وثانيه عام 2014 وثالثه مع بدء
الحرب الحاليه ليصبح العدد اقل من 30
مليون نسمه بعد ان غادر البلاد نحو تسعه
ملايين
ولا يقتصر التغيير الديموغرافي على من
غادر بل على من نزح من مناطق الجنوب
والشرق التي سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه
بينما تبقى الاسئله حاضره عما بقي في تلك
المناطق
هي احدى المشكلات الرئيسيه في الغرب
فالمزيد من المسنين يؤثر سلبا على
الاقتصاد لغياب الشباب لذلك فهو يهدد
البلاد اوكرانيات تعاني من زياده عدد
المسنين وخسرنا الكثير من الشباب والاطفال
لكننا متفائلون بعودتهم المشكله الاكبر هي
قضيه سكان الذين كانوا يعيشون في المناطق
المحتله نظرا لان اعاده الاعمار لاحقا لن
تكون مهمه سهله
اذا هي معركه اخرى تخوضها اوكرانيا قوامها
الارقام ومخاوف من نسيج اجتماعي يحاك
بخيوط الفقد والنزوح واللجوء عدنان
الجزيره كيف